today on the matt wall show the mask
mandates are returning and you're not
allowed to question it this is how
science works now namely like religious
dogma also we have our five headlines
including the capital officers
continuing their media tour and a former
president of planned parenthood says
that she was shocked to discover that
planned parenthood only cares about
abortion what do you know and gender
theory begins to make inroads into
medical school which is a terrifying
thought in our daily cancellation i will
respond to the outraged masses that have
been trying to cancel me
over the past two days it'll be another
inspiring reverse cancellation all of
that and more today on the matt wall
show want to begin today by talking
about masks
and vaccines
just a little bit of behind-the-scenes
information here you should know that
our
big tech overlords have placed many
landmines just under the surface when it
comes to the subject and you step on one
and they take you down
you you're blown up to smithereens and
you're done
uh they don't want us asking any
questions about masks about vaccines
about anything
except that they they can't come out
directly and say don't ask any questions
about any of these subjects
instead they have a whole list of
statements that you're not allowed to
make statements that are
anti-scientific they say
claims that are misinformation
they claim
can't say any of that and if you make
those statements they'll simply take
your platform away and that'll be the
end of it
now i know some of you listening are
probably saying well hey don't don't let
the man control you man charge out there
step on those minds to prove a point
blow yourself up on principle on purpose
there is something that seems noble
about that i admit and appealing on an
emotional level except that um that's
exactly what they want you to do
because then you're gone and your voice
is gone and they don't have to worry
about you anymore
they want the excuse to silence you
so the game i think is to speak the
truth and question the narrative
and never speak untruth ever under any
circumstance without performing an act
of intentional self-immolation at the
same time
but the fact that these rules are in
place
should really tell you something
i mean it tells you that none of this
has anything to do with science
here's how you know that someone or some
institution
or some social media platform
doesn't care about science
if they don't want to want you to ask
questions
that's a dead giveaway
because science welcomes questions
scientifically minded people are eager
for questions they want their positions
to be challenged
and if that sounds rare if it sounds
rare that you would actually encounter
someone who likes it when their
positions are challenged well it just
tells you that scientifically minded
people are rare
science that cannot be challenged is not
science it is dogma
telling someone that they shouldn't
question the science
i mean it's like a fitness instructor
telling someone that uh they shouldn't
physically move
you know you're you're you're at you you
go for physical fitness training and the
first thing they tell you i don't know
don't move just just stay ready sit down
sit down don't move
there is no physical fitness that
doesn't involve movement
just as there's no scientific process
that doesn't involve questioning
there is no settled science either that
doesn't exist
especially because there is no single
cosmic scientific authority who can come
along and declare it's settled
when people talk about oh it's settled
science
who exactly decided that it was who
determined that
science constantly evolves constantly
questions itself constantly learns new
things
science is also transparent if an
institution makes a claim or a mandate
or recommendation
and they won't tell you why they've made
it
or show you the data that led to that
decision then that institution is not a
scientific institution
and that's why the cdc for example is
not a scientific institution by this
standard
here's a good example as to why from a
report on fox news this morning it says
more than a day after issuing new
guidance that vaccinated people should
wear masks indoors recommendations that
are likely to affect millions of
americans in the form of private and
public mass mandates the center for
for disease control and prevention has
yet to release the data behind its
decision the lack of clarity on what
exactly the agency is basing its
decision on comes as states and cities
across the country are working to
vaccinate more of their citizens and
it's making some local officials
reluctant to follow the cdc's device on
nearly universal
masking
quote this is from new york city health
and hospitals president and ceo mitchell
katz he said while the cdc issued their
guidance yesterday at about 3 p.m
they have not yet released their
scientific reports on the data that
underlies the recommendation he said at
a press conference with mayor bill de
blasio
this has been of course the way that our
public health authorities public health
authorities in quotes have operated from
the very beginning they tell us what to
do but don't bother to tell us why we
should do those things except in the
most vague terms
a question like
what exact data
led to this conclusion
is rarely answered in a direct and clear
way instead we're expected to simply do
as we're told even if what we're told is
the opposite of what those same
authorities told us five seconds ago
it's a game it's like a game of simon
says if you remember that game as a kid
the the moves that you make in a game of
simon says
are random by design there's no point to
the move itself
the point is obedience that's the game
and that's certainly the case here now
that mask mandates are returning across
the country even for vaccinated people
they've returned in congress too where
the capital physician has now declared
that everyone in the capital must wear
masks again vaccinated or not
house minority leader kevin mccarthy
questioned this decision that is he
when i say question the decision
he sided with the cdc of five seconds
ago
rather than the cdc of right now
and for this he was called a [ __ ] by
nancy pelosi and then he was taken to
task by representative tim ryan in a
rousing floor speech
defending masking vaccinated people
here's what tim ryan said
look
the attending physician of the united
states capital
the top doctor for congress
asked us to put on masks when we come to
a chamber with 435 people i hate these
things
absolutely it was terrible having to put
this back on
and we do it because the top doctor for
all of us
asked us to
and
i i may not be from a hot spot
speaker may not be from a hot spot
speaker pelosi may not be from a hot
spot
somebody in this chamber is coming from
a hot spot
somebody represents the hot spots
and they get in a plane and they fly
here and they interact with all of us
and then we leave here
and we go home to our families
some
take care of their sick parents
some take care of kids who may have an
autoimmune
disorder and i just find it absolutely
immature
and appalling
to somehow diminish it to try to score
cheap political points and that's
exactly what we saw
a few minutes ago appalling it is
appalling to question putting on a mask
when you're vaccinated
even though you were just told you don't
have to now you're told you have to
appalling
who could question this the physician
the attending physician has spoken
we must not question him
we must not apply our own mental powers
to the situation and come to any
conclusions on our own
but you'll notice what's missing from
tim ryan's rant and it's the same thing
missing from the cdc's latest
declaration it's the same thing that's
always missing with the mask called this
and that is again again data
uh reasons
and most of all
an answer to this question
how much risk is acceptable
although these people won't talk about
it
the fact is that the data tells us
there's a fraction of a fraction of a
percent of a chance that a vaccinated
person will get seriously sick from
virus it is unlikely that he will
contract contract contract it or spread
it also
and not just vaccinate people studies
have been done
indicating that those with natural
immunity we don't talk about natural
immunity but those who've previously had
covet had natural immunity
studies indicate they have lasting
protection maybe even better protection
than vaccinated people
studies indicate
and this is all the case without masks
the risk that covid poses to people in
these um
in these groups
appears to be very small
just as the risk that it poses to
children
appears to be very small
so again the question if a very small
risk is not tolerable
then how much risk is tolerable
that is a fair question
fauci the cdc the public health experts
on tv the democrats in congress
none of these people have ever even
attempted to answer it
they haven't engaged with it at all they
won't acknowledge it
but it's not only a fair question it is
the question
the number one question we cannot have a
public health policy without an answer
to it how much risk is tolerable
all public health policy must be must be
crafted around this question
it's the fundamental question
how much risk is tolerable how much risk
is acceptable
only until you know the answer to that
question can you come up with any kind
of policy for anything
related to public health
we can only assume though they won't
directly say it
that they believe a very small risk is
not tolerable
again they won't come out and say that
but that is clearly what they're
indicating
even when your risk is in the range of a
fraction of a fraction of a percent it
is still not tolerable
what they seem to want what their goal
seems to be is zero risk
that's an issue because it's not
possible
to live a zero risk life if we are
pretending that any risk is high risk
that there's no meaningful distinction
between something that is almost certain
to kill you and something that almost
certainly won't
then we can't have a human society
someone told me today that uh going
around without a mask
is like driving without breaks
but driving without breaks
is certain to result in serious injury
or death
going around without a mask vaccinated
or not
does not carry anything like that kind
of certainty
if we have collapsed this distinction
if all risk is just risk and all of it
is unacceptable
well i'm not taking any risks
we can't take any risks we can't take
risks with our children we can't take
risks with the vulnerable if that's what
we're saying now
doesn't matter
doesn't matter how much just can't take
a risk
well then we can't live
we can't have a civilization
we can't
you cannot function that way it is not
possible
am i saying that civilization collapses
if people wear masks
no not exactly i'm saying that
civilization collapses
if people have decided that there is no
amount of physical risk which they are
willing to endure
it is not possible to function that way
we cannot go on like this
we simply can't
and it is as simple as that i believe
now let's get to our five headlines
now a quick word from legacy box you
know some so much of your own identity
is tied up in your memories and as they
say if you if you want to know who you
are you have to know where you've been
and who you've been but what if you have
a bunch of old camcorder tapes and old
photographs that have been destroyed
they're in a box somewhere you're not
going to know who you've been you're not
going to know your own identity now
you'll be doomed to wander the
countryside a ghost a mere figment not
knowing yourself
that's why you need legacy bucks legacy
box is a super simple mail-in service to
have all of your video tapes camcorder
tapes film reels and pictures digitally
preserved on a thumb drive dvd or the
cloud legacy box is a way for you to
easily and affordably digitally preserve
your pass
the process from start to finish is
really easy you pack and send
their team digitizes everything by hand
and then they send it back to you and
you enjoy it it's as simple as that
legacy box is the world's largest
digitizer of home movies and photos and
has helped over 850 thousand families
preserve their past so do that now
preserve your your past figure out who
you are today get start get started uh
future proof proofing your memories
today so you can gather the family and
begin the trip down memory lane go to
legacy box dot com walsh to get an
incredible 40 off your first order again
legacy box dot com slash walsh and say
40 off while supplies last
all right so tell me what you think
about this um i need your opinion on
this before we really get into the
headlines here my my uh my wife is
uh first of all an excellent homemaker
home designer decorator incredibly
talented in that department uh if i was
in charge of that we'd have cardboard
boxes as furniture furniture we'd have
maybe um our only decorations would be
like old beer bottles
and but but but the fancy ones i mean
you know because i do have some class
i'm not saying i would just leave beer
by i'm saying you know you get those
beer bottles like a nice ipa and they
got the fancy dr
then they're fancy drawings on the on
the ipas yeah i would probably leave
some of those out because they look nice
um anyway but my wife it has more
sophisticated tastes than that however
she she sometimes makes choices that i
don't agree with
and um so she uh we have some things in
our house
i think like every like suburban family
we have uh some of these things up on
the wall
that are like inspirational slogans you
know
and uh so one that she really likes that
she got somewhere
in it's the the slogan is
be fearless in pursuit of what sets your
soul on fire that's the slogan
and my first problem with it is just
like that is so not me i mean i do live
in this house too right this is also
partially my house is it not and i think
anyone comes over and they see that
they're just gonna think
he lives here with that thing
but then um you know we moved and and uh
we're getting everything set up in the
new house
and so she takes this
thing the inspirational slogan
and she puts it up in the bathroom
and so that's a choice i find confusing
like who needs to be inspired that way
in the bathroom
i
i have been this is what comes to mind
for me i have been in the bathroom
feeling like my soul is on fire
but that's because i had too much
chipotle
and i want to go into detail
so that's my issue but maybe maybe
maybe the bathroom is a great place for
for inspiration i don't know especially
if you're
staring in the mirror doing your morning
affirmations maybe that's the idea here
all right um so the left-wing capital
police officer officer dunn was on cnn
last night like the other officers he's
been kind of doing this media tour
all over the place and uh and by the way
we we know that he's i'm not saying that
he's left-wing simply because he showed
up at this uh theater performance that
did what they're calling the january 6
commission
oh that's a pretty good indication of
itself but we also have we know from his
statements on social media it's very
clear what his political leanings are
and uh he was on cnn last night
where he addressed the comparison
between january 6th and the blm riots
and he explained why january 6 was was
so much worse let's listen
first amendment protest is what this
country is about
the first amendment the constitution
like
that's the democracy of it but once you
start
attacking people attacking things then
that's wrong and that and you know what
that goes to the riots this summer they
were wrong if you peacefully protest
then sure but the riots and the the
violence and the damage this summer
they were wrong
they were wrong and that's the exact
same thing that happened at the capitol
but their goal was to overthrow
democracy which is a bigger threat to
america
to overthrow so it's worse because they
were trying to overthrow
democracy first of all
this of course we we've heard this so
many times they were trying to overthrow
democracy
even uh which which
to begin with
assumes that
these people going into the capital
building all had a plan and a plot
altogether and there was a there was a
you know there was a
real reason that they were there and
they were they had something they were
trying to achieve
but meanwhile when you look at the
footage you see plenty of people just
kind of like milling around
someone steals a lectern someone goes
into nancy pelosi's office puts puts to
take some selfies that's that was their
plan for over throwing democracy see i'm
i'm
very skeptical
that that in fact was the plan in the
minds of most of the people in the
building that day
just based on what actually happened
but even if that was the plan
does that mean that there was actually a
threat of it really happening
there could be all kinds of wackos that
come up with all kinds of plans and the
plans can be very bad
but to say that um well this is this was
a
serious threat as if it is because it
was a plan that means that it almost
happened we're going to operate as if
this was a that was a that was an
outcome that was within the realm of
possibility that's what we're meant to
believe here
which again assuming that that even was
a plan
the guy stealing the lectern
he he did that because he wanted to
overthrow democracy
okay
well
it it's it's funny though of course
because no one has been of of all the
people involved in this that have been
hunted down and arrested
and all of them have been
none of them have been charged with
anything like that
no one's been charged with treason
or sedition or any of these all of these
words that are that are thrown out to
describe it none of them charged with
that which is interesting
is that because the courts aren't taking
it seriously don't want to hold these
people accountable obviously not
they're sending swat teams after old
grandmas
who took pictures you know in the in the
lobby
so they're obviously trying to put
whatever charges they can on these
people but they can't put treason on
them
because there's simply no evidence for
it at all
so that you could just respond that way
to the claim made by officer dunn there
but at such an absurd claim my point is
even if i agreed that they wanted to do
that
there was zero chance of it actually
happening
there was no there was no possibility
that democracy was going to be
overthrown that day
that was not
anywhere within the vicinity of
something that might have actually
happened
do you think that our system of
government
our democracy is so weak and infirm and
vulnerable that it could be overthrown
that way
by a crowd of hooligans trespassing
and taking selfies you think you think
they could they might have actually
pulled it off
so it's just an absurd claim to begin
with
um
and at any rate if that is an attempt to
overthrow democracy
then as we've said a million times
going into a police station in the
middle of a major american city and
burning it to the ground what do you
call that
if going into the capital building is an
attack on our system of government well
then what about burning down a police
station
there really is i he's he's correct in a
way that that there really is no
comparison between the blm riots and
january 6th
because the blm riots were so clearly
in every way
worse
and a much greater threat you know
there's there's the actual damage that
was done during these riots
which again much worse we're talking
billions of dollars of damage there's
not anything like that kind of damage
that was done during the capital
riots um
we're talking dozens of people killed uh
hundreds of of buildings destroyed
businesses destroyed all that during the
blm ride so
the immediate physical and financial
toll
the toll and blow in both blood and
money was much greater
but also what about what about the
broader implications
you know
i'm not going to say that the blm riots
was an attack on democracy i don't even
think that it was it was much more than
that it's worse than that actually
it's an attack on the rule of law
and you want to talk about things that
we need in order to have a human
civilization
there are different forms of government
okay
that that can that can work for a
civilization clearly
but you cannot have a civilization
without rule of law
that you can't do
and this was a fundamental attack on the
rule of law
not just by the rioters
but by
very prominent people people in high
positions of power
going all the way up to the guy who's
currently in the white house right now
encouraging it
justifying it
either directly or implicitly saying
that uh the rule of law it doesn't
really apply to these people in this
situation because they're very upset and
if you're very upset then we have to
understand and you know
give them room to destroy as the mayor
of baltimore famously once said
that is a direct assault on the on the
rule of law and we're seeing the
implications we're seeing the results of
it right now
uh a you know crime violent crime out of
control
much worse than it's
been in decades in many of these cities
all right let's move on
to uh
some interesting news about planned
parenthood so life site news has this
and
you you hopefully know that planned
parenthood is
the number one abortion conglomerate in
america
uh number one abortion provider as they
would call themselves
they slaughter over 300 000 children
every single year
um
you know they are
they have they have killed
millions and millions of people
of human beings babies
this obviously is their number one
priority
is abortion
that's how they make most of their money
you know you want to you you look at
where they make their income
and it's abortion
and tax money that's that's that's where
it all that's where almost all of it
comes from
um
now
planned parenthood in public will say
that's not the case and planned
parenthood's defenders will often say
things like oh
abortion is only three percent of what
they do i'm sure you've heard that
figure before three percent
it's only three percent of their
business that's all
trying to make it sound like it's it's
certainly not the main focus it doesn't
even really matter that much
you could take abortion away it would
have have almost no impact on the on the
institution at all
which already is sort of interesting
because if it's that if it's if it's
that
small
and if it hardly matters then why does
planned parenthood defend it as
viciously as they do but we know that
the three percent figure is total
nonsense the way that they get to that
number
and as always you know
um
this is how you can lie with a statistic
the way they get to that number is by
unbundling what they would call
unbundling their services
and then and then sort of weighting all
of the services the same
so
um
you know an analogy would be something
like maybe a a car dealership
if they were to sell three cars
and then also sell 100 water bottles
from their vending machine
then then and then they turn around and
say well selling cars is only three
percent of what we do
but really we're a water bottle
distributor primarily
but
when you when you look at where they
make their money it's in selling cars
not water bottles
and so there's a bunch of other things
that planned parenthood does
in theory you go there you could get um
birth control for example
there are other services they provide
and they may even provide those services
like something like giving away free
birth control easy enough to do that's a
really easy service to provide
they may provide those services more
often than they perform abortions
but
abortion is the central piece of their
business
and of all the services they provide
that's where they make the lion's share
of their income
okay that's the reality
but many people are confused on this
point including the former president of
planned parenthood herself
so here's what lifesitenews reports they
say
in her memoir published on july 27th dr
liana wen details her time spent as
president of the nation's largest
abortion provider planned parenthood
gwen offers readers an insider's view of
the organization's obsession with
abortion in lifeline a doctor's journey
in the fight for public health
among other things she says that she was
told to say abortion in every media
interview someone also warned her that
if we don't talk about abortion openly
loudly and proudly as a positive moral
good then we're further stigmatizing it
uh wen served as president for eight
short months before planned parenthood
suddenly ended her employment during a
secret meeting in 2019
um at the time she'd share she said that
she left because of philosophical
differences now she's written this sort
of this expose
um talking about what really happened
behind the scenes
uh it says as she reveals in her book
wen faced opposition from planned
parenthood from the very beginning of
how because of how she handled abortion
uh quote one of the main points i wanted
to get across was that healthcare
shouldn't be political she remembered
from when she prepared for her first
media appearance as president on abc's
the view
i'd come to this job as a doctor and my
charge was patients lives
her message was met with applause and
cheering from the show's audience she
said but not from planned parenthood
less than an hour after the messages
started coming some of which threw her
off guard first a board member texted
her saying next time make sure you talk
about abortion then someone else said
then two people on the national staff
informed her that back in the office
there was a lot of worried chatter
did i leave out abortion on purpose they
wondered wen said was this a signal that
i didn't want to defend access to
abortion
um one of them also advised her to next
time just say the word
the unnamed person added you need to
talk about abortion at every media
interview you're the president of
planned parenthood people expect that
from you
this caused when to reevaluate planned
parenthood and she says until that
moment i thought the overriding reason
planned parenthood was equated with
abortion instead of its other health
care services was the anti-choice
opposition
i was taken aback to see that it wasn't
just the anti-choice side that wanted to
bet to brand planned parenthood with
abortion
this is
really kind of amazing
you you've got a woman
who was uh the president of planned
parenthood
only for eight months which is she's a
medical she's a doctor
medical professional
grown adult
obviously familiar with these issues
becomes the president of planned
parenthood and she was shocked to
discover
that planned parenthood cares only about
abortion
this is what she talks about in the book
anytime she was in front of the media
all they wanted her to do was talk about
abortion
this this came as a surprise to her
now i have never stepped foot inside of
a planned parenthood and never would
i could have told you that
clearly this is what they do this is
where they make their money this is what
they care about
it just shows you how thoroughly uh
people have been deluded
and how successful planned parenthood
has been and you know let's not give
them too much credit
uh it's easy to be successful with this
when you have the entire media on your
side when the entire media is a
propaganda organ for you
then it's easy to be successful in
deluding the public
into thinking that you're primarily a
healthcare clinic and you know you do
abortions on the side here and there
yes you will you will viciously defend
abortion at every step
you will not allow any criticism about
or any questions about it
but it's not that big of a deal
this is how diluted people are
um
and they have to be
you know the planned parenthood needs
people to be diluted in this way
because if you actually began to see
planned parenthood for what it is
and you really stopped
to think about this
this is a company that has made
billions of dollars from killing people
and they kill
300 000 humans every year
um when you when you stop and think
about that you know it's it's kind of
hard to just drive by them
on your way to work and see them in some
shopping mall
and say oh it's planned parenthood just
like any other business
um all right let's see what else we got
here uh
from
maybe we'll save this for tomorrow or
maybe not barry weiss on her sub stack
has a report written by katie herzog
that's uh it's really a must read and
it's about the infiltration of gender
theory into medical school
um
so here's uh
here's a little bit of it
so it says during a recent endocrinology
course at a top medical school in the
university of california system a
professor stopped mid-lecture to
apologize for something he'd said at the
beginning of the class
quote i don't want you to think that i'm
in any way trying to imply anything
and if you can summon some generosity
forgive me i would really appreciate it
the physician says in a recording
provided by a student in the class who
will call lauren
again i'm very sorry for that it was uh
it was certainly not my intention to
offend anyone the worst thing that i
could do as a human being is be
offensive
his offense
using the term pregnant woman
okay this is in medical school
we're gonna go right past the statement
the worst thing i can do as a human
being
is be offensive how
how revealing is that
someone who believes that the worst
thing you can do
it's not murder it's not rape the worst
thing it's not it's not uh pedophilia no
the worst thing is to offend someone
with your words
and he really believes that
quote i said when a woman is pregnant
which implies that only women can get
pregnant and i most sincerely apologize
to all of you
it wasn't the first time that lauren had
heard an instructor apologize for using
language that to most americans would
seem utterly inoffensive words like male
and female
why would medical school professors
apologize for referring to a patient's
biological sex because lauren explains
in the context of her medical school
acknowledging biological sex can be
considered transphobic
when sex is acknowledged by instructors
it's sometimes portrayed as a social
construct not a biological reality
in a lecture on transgender health an
instructor declared biological sex
sexual orientation and gender are all
constructs
these are all constructs that we have
created
i can't read it's worth going uh to
barry white's substance finding that and
reading the whole report it is this is
bone chilling stuff not surprising we
knew it was going to get to this
gender theory had made its inroads into
grade school
um
you know into undergraduate courses and
it was only a matter of time before it
would
fully
intrude into medical school
of course
the problem is a pretty significant one
is that you you cannot do medicine
if you don't recognize biological
reality that is the foundation of
medicine
is human biology and understanding human
biology you you cannot be a doctor who
doesn't understand human biology because
this is what you're working with this is
what you're trying to treat
so if you don't understand it or
are not going to allow yourself to
acknowledge it
then medicine ceases to exist
we also know that this was
this was inevitable this uh
we were always going to get to this
point
you know
once we allowed
this artificial bifurcation of sex and
gender
gender
up until the 1950s and 1960s
nobody talked about human beings having
a gender there was no need for the term
there still is no need for it
we don't need to talk about that you
have a sex and that's what you have
there's no need for to go any further
than that
and we have the words masculinity and
femininity to talk about the way that uh
that that men and women typically act
and the way that they interact with the
world so we already have those terms
and if you had a man who acts in a more
feminine way then you could just say
that you don't need to talk about well
his gender he's his sex is male but his
gender is female because he acts in a
feminine way
adding this extra label into it only
confuses matters by intentionally
but the gender theory proponents the
gender series cultists really
for decades
after introducing after taking gender
from the realm of of language which is
where it had been before
words had gender
okay obviously you can't talk about a
word having a biological sex but a word
can have gender gendered language which
is now offensive
so we took that out of the
realm of language started applying it to
people
and for decades we were told
that's two different things you have
your biological sex and you have your
gender
um
lots of people went along with that
that became a kind of this this
mainstream understanding that people had
even though it really didn't make any
sense and now what we're watching over
the last couple of years and it is a
very significant development
and it was also entirely inevitable it's
always going to go this way
we're watching that distinction once
again collapse
now it's just it's the same thing sex
and gender once again are the same thing
except that
now really when we talk about the
distinction being collapsed we've just
erased biological sex and now there is
only gender
and you can use sex to refer to gender
but that's all that really is that all
there is is the human construct
something to keep in mind you know
going forward when you go to the doctor
you might want to do a quick quiz just
before deciding who your primary care
physician is going to be
this might be an important thing to do
uh you know they'll they'll do a checkup
with you they'll do a kind of a
preliminary physical well you might want
to do a preliminary checkup with them
and ask them a few questions like hey
hey doc by the way can can a man get
pregnant
if they say yes to that they say
anything but no go find another doctor
all right uh finally before we get to
reading the comments as we've been
talking about you know how cowardice is
being repackaged as courage here's
another great example also from this
week as you know the cleveland indians
got uh got rid of their name because
it's offensive even though it's very
much not offensive at all and now uh now
they put out a psa or a promo video
voiced by tom hanks
trying to sell this change
trying to sell their new image as the
cleveland guardians
and really it's it's heroic and
inspiring how they've given up on the
name that they had for a century let's
listen to that
and now it's time
to unite as one family one community to
build the next era for this team and
this city
to keep watch and guard what makes this
game the greatest
to come together and welcome all who
want to join us
we are loyal and proud and resilient we
protect what we've earned and always
defend it
together we stand with all who
understand what it means to be born and
built from the land
because this is the city we love
and the game we believe in
and together
we are all
cleveland guardians
we are
we are loyal
proud
uh we defend ourselves we defend who we
are
no that's the exact opposite of what you
did you you apologized for who you were
and you changed because people were mad
and
it just admit that
it's the same thing with simone biles
trying to repackage cowardice
giving up
caving
as some
some sort of inspiring and you know
courageous act don't don't give me that
you can just say we all we all know what
you did
people were mad
and uh you want people to be mad at you
so you changed the name even though even
though there's nothing wrong with it
that's it
i'm not gonna say i would i respect that
move but at least respect the honesty
all right let's move now to reading the
youtube comments
this is from a user also named matt said
matt's entire demeanor even his voice
changes when he starts yelling if he was
my dad i'd be terrified of him because i
would just assume there's a different
person who isn't my father that comes
out when he's mad
doesn't everyone's voice and demeanor
change when they yell isn't that a
pretty common thing for yelling how
would you yell if your voice didn't
change at all
not quite under sure i understand that
uh mike says been a self-absorbed coward
all my life finally it's cool
well congratulations
and you joke well maybe you're joking i
don't know if you are not
but
that is actually what's happening here
it's a very self-serving thing
uh we talked about this on the backstage
last night
that
the people who are defending simone
biles and um
not just saying oh we should be
understanding of her quitting but saying
it's actually courageous
because she's protecting her mental
health and she's living her truth and
all this stuff she's looking out for
herself
putting herself before her team in her
country
the people who are doing that is a very
there's a very self-serving reason for
it
because if now it is if it's courageous
for simone biles
to quit
when it's hard
to put her mental well-being above
everybody else
that means it's courageous when i do it
too
and i can do that because that's very
easy
you know to say that it's courageous for
an olympic athlete
to not cave under the pressure but to to
to to uh
keep trying in spite of it
and to persevere and push forward
if i say that that's courageous and
admirable and it is
well that is something that i can't do
and so i'm admiring someone for
something that that uh i'm not an
olympic athlete i can't be one
i could never pull that off so i'm
admiring someone for doing something
that i can't do
and admiring someone for doing something
you can't do there has to be a certain
element of humility in that
but admiring someone for doing something
that you do all the time
there's no humility it's very
self-serving and i think that that's
what a lot of this is about
michael says matt you should have a
series where you respond to other
conservatives calling you out would be
very entertaining for example the
amazing lucas who is hardly amazing
recently posted a video about the
olympic subject calling you out by name
i have no idea
who that is the amazing lucas is what he
actually calls himself is he a magician
garf says i want to call my boss and
tell him that i'm going to be radically
courageous
well
you can now and he has to respect you
living your truth
um the conservative midwife says no one
had called them speaking of the officer
dunn the officer who said that he was
called the n-word
by the capital by the
capital writers said no one had called
them the n-word in their whole careers
not even after 45 years yet suddenly th
that specific day multiple people did it
several times he had an entire crowd of
people
and i noticed that too in his the claims
that he made before congress
he said he went his whole career
as a as a black police officer never
been been called the n-word before which
is great
and then you have whole crowds of people
doing it
and none of it's on video
and
robert says matt in the 22 years of our
marriage my wife has caught me crying
just once
it was the ending of ole yeller
uh i i i'm there there are movies i said
rudy yesterday the end of rudy
when he goes out there he's finally
living his dreams he's he has persevered
through everything and he makes it out
there and he makes a tackle
you know it's a it's a meaningless game
it doesn't matter but it but it means so
much to him
you can cry for that that i think a few
dignified manly tears
there are a couple other movies that i
would throw into that too
not old yeller though
like a dog
i i can't i can't give you a pass on
that
and joshua says matt's comments on what
it means to truly be a man were so
beautiful that it made me cry well there
you go there is another exception
that certainly i think we can all
agree is an exception uh if you were
moved to town and i will say this in
fact it's important to say this right
now
if you're a man
listening to this show
um and you're moved to tears of of of
joy and inspiration by anything that i
say
that is perfectly okay
i know that my words are that powerful
and i would never judge you for it
you absolute pansy
you may have heard us mention a time or
two that ben shapiro's new book the
authoritarian moment has finally hit
shelves and uh it's time to read up on
some truth ben's book couldn't have been
written at a time more important in our
country's history as the left increases
their
iron grip on our institutions
entertainment media education everything
else our country becomes further divided
and more susceptible to authoritarian
control for example the cdc's guidance
on masks and vaccines as we have talked
about uh it's just another example of
the authoritarianism that we're
witnessing today the authoritarian
moment is all about all of that it gives
you all the tools you need uh not only
to understand what's happening but to
respond to it as well and it's now
available at amazon barnes noble or any
other major bookseller so you can get
your copy today you can also pick up an
autographed copy for just 30 bucks at
dailywire.com ben and leave a five star
review to help amplify conservative
voices
speaking of conservative voices it uh
seems we can't go a day without fresh
terrible news about how our
authoritarian overlords are attempting
to squeeze americans of every last bit
of our freedom which is why i think it's
important that i actually provide some
good news for you right now if you've
ever thought that it'd be cool to travel
on the daily wires dime to nashville
studios to smoke a cigar with the hosts
then you just might be in luck because
if you're not a member yet this is your
chance head to dailywire.com subscribe
and use code backstage to get 25 off
your new membership and be automatically
entered to win two tickets to lounge
with the daily wire legends
oh we've been promoted we're daily wire
legends now backstage and uh that's not
all you get to take home copy
take home signed copies of michael and
ben's newest books
and uh
and matt's book no it's not on here okay
you don't get my book doesn't count if
none of that entices you just remember
you unlike most people will get to meet
uh me as well but you won't get my book
so head to dailywire.com subscribe with
code backstage get 25 off your
membership and a chance to win the
ultimate backstage experience now let's
get to our daily cancellation
today we'll be canceling the internet
rage mob that has been coming after me
for the past two days the rage mob has
once again
really taught me a lesson by causing my
name to trend nationally on twitter i
have to say as a media personality and
podcast host there is nothing worse
than nationwide attention
that's why i begged the outrage masses
to stop giving me traffic i pleaded with
them i said no no pl please don't
please don't make me into one of the top
subjects of conversation on social media
that is the last thing i want please
please stop talking about me
but they didn't listen
and so tragically i was forced to gain
many new podcast and newsletter
subscribers and twitter followers by the
way you can subscribe to my newsletter
mattwalchreport.com
my enemies have completely owned and
destroyed me
by giving me publicity
it's not the first time that they've
done that and i fear that it may not be
the last
the source of the outrage has been so
far as i could tell my tweets on two of
the subjects we discussed on this show
yesterday one of those subjects is of
course simone biles
many thousands of people have eagerly
informed me that i am a horrendous
monster a bigot a racist a sexist an
ugly loser an idiot among other things
for failing to applaud biles for her
courage in quitting on her team and her
country uh one person after another
including lots of people in media
hollywood the sports world and so on
lined up to let me know how wrong and
stupid i am
and most of them especially took issue
with a comparison that i drew to michael
jordan where i pointed out
that jordan
would would would never have quit in the
middle of a game in the playoffs in
order to protect his emotional and
mental well-being he never would have
done that
famously he was he was horribly sick
with the flu and he still went out and
played
now i've been told
many times over
that this is a stupid analogy because
michael jordan did quit he left the game
in his prime and played baseball and
then went back to basketball aha you see
it's the same thing how much of a [ __ ]
can i be
i have been dunked on they got me how
will i recover
what can i possibly say in response to
that
well there is one thing i could say i
could point out that michael jordan
didn't leave the game of basketball
during a game of basketball
that's not what we mean when we say he
left the game
jordan in fact waited until the off
season and that's when he retired
the off-season is not the same as during
the season
much less during a game
off-season
as opposed to in season
do you see the difference
outrage mob do you
i'm speaking slowly and using
small words
because i want to help you
off
versus in
does that distinction register at all
you see you see i i'm not claiming
that no athlete should ever retire from
a sport
i'm not over here castigating terry
bradshaw because he isn't still playing
quarterback for the steelers at the age
of 72. i i am aware that athletes at a
certain point will stop being athletes
it's just like you might notice you know
i am not currently playing checkers
though i have played checkers in the
past i i have i have played checkers
and then i have stopped playing checkers
but i stop playing it after the game is
over
i stop playing after the game is over
um and that means you can't call me a
quitter if i stop playing during the
game then i am a quitter
athletes who decide to stop playing in
the middle of a competition are quitters
by definition athletes who stop playing
after a competition are retired
i'm not sure how to explain this if
you're still confused
perhaps maybe draw pictures
i could make my point through some sort
of interpretive dance
i just don't know how to make this any
clearer or simpler
hopefully that will be enough
but the outrage directed towards me over
my simone biles opinions has paled in
comparison to the fury that has greeted
my position
on the subject of men crying
as i mentioned yesterday i tweeted that
men should not cry in public because
it's dishonorable and unmanly
though i allow for certain exceptions
which i have outlined in further detail
in the past um perhaps i should publish
an official list you know with an index
and a glossary and a bibliography and
everything so that any man if he's
considering crying can quickly consult
the rule book and find out if he's if
his upcoming sobbing fit meets the
requirements you know is this going to
be sanctioned crying or not
but that's a project for another day for
now i can tell you that people have been
very
very very upset
about this ironically thousands of men
have cried publicly over the fact that i
said they shouldn't cry publicly
there there have also been some
unexpected voices chiming in to
castigate me including one of one of the
guys from blink182 which was funny and
speaking of funny there have been lots
of responses like this from a guy named
um andy ostroy who described himself as
a filmmaker and a proud democrat he said
i cry
i cry often and i'm more man than you'll
ever be
now it's not often that you hear someone
unironically use the phrase i'm more man
than you'll ever be and you certainly
don't hear it said right after the words
i cry often
but these are the kinds of landmarks
like landmark occasions that twitter has
made possible and we should be grateful
for that
i should note that some of these crying
men have made physical threats including
a guy named ronnie ficaro
some kind of musician
and he said quote
i don't know who the f you are but i
don't like you at all actually i'd love
to punch you in your stupid little face
and make you cry you little [ __ ] boy
toxic waste of space
immediately after writing that ronnie
deleted
deleted the tweet and blocked me
i'm gonna punch you
runs away crying
now i have to say i have never felt less
threatened by physical threats
look it's
it's easy to mock and make fun of these
people um
and to point at them and say ha ha
you're crying
and and and frankly it's a lot of fun
and we should do that
but what i'd really like to respond to
are the accusations leveled repeatedly
at me over the past two day or two
that i only say things like this
like it's dishonorable for men to cry in
public because i'm trying to shock and
offend someone actually called me a
shock tweeter
which incidentally is how i describe
myself on my resume
shock tweeter
is that true though do i say these sorts
of things merely to cause shock and
outrage and defense
the answer is yes
at least partly
the first reason that i say what i say
is that it's true and it's always worth
saying true things
but i am aware
that a statement like the one i made
about crying in public will provoke a
reaction i know that
i say it anyway not in spite of the
reaction it will cause but yes partly
because of that reaction
the point is not simply to selfishly
profit off of the outrage mob's anger
though that is one perk that i quite
enjoy
the greater point is that most of the
things i say including the idea
that men should usually refrain from
crying in public
that's all that is really being said
here
usually men should try not to cry in
public
that's it
these are completely common sense
completely unobjectionable things the
kinds of things that if i had said at
any other point in history in front of
almost any other audience anywhere
people would have yawned and said well
yeah what's your point
it would have seemed utterly obvious to
almost everyone who has ever lived
and yet now we're supposed to believe
that these obvious common sense
statements are not only wrong but absurd
outrageous insane i have actually been
been accused of insanity literal
insanity for saying that men shouldn't
go around crying all the time
we can think of many other common sense
statements that provoke this kind of
reaction a statement like for example
men can't get pregnant that will even
shock people in medical school now
or or women are weaker than men
plenty of other examples come to mind
it's not simply that the mob will
disagree with these claims now
it's that they will treat the claims as
outright lunacy
they will react to a man speaking common
sense as if he is a raving maniac
and this tactic is extremely effective
because after a while
if you're not careful you're going to be
brow beat into thinking well if everyone
thinks that the idea is that offensive i
must be wrong
but you're not wrong
you you have not only rationality and
logic on your side and common sense but
the near universal consensus of all
mankind until about 12 seconds ago
only now
you know
is it that you're you're not supposed to
say those things anymore
and that's exactly why i say them
the more that people scream
and cry in the face of normal
inoffensive statements the more i will
say them
the more we should all say them
simply out of principle
and because it's true
and because it's funny to see you so mad
so to the outraged mob today
i must say
you are canceled
and please stop crying you're
embarrassing me
that'll do it for today thanks for
watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
our technical directors austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show was edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
21.
john vickley here editor-in-chief of
daily wire wake up every morning with
our new show morning wire on today's
show the biden administration moves to
impose federal vaccine mandates canadian
churches are targeted by arsonists and
the supreme court agrees to hear a case
that could impact roe v wade join us and
get the facts first on the news you need
to know with our show morning wire